can I take CBD for a paid? It's interesting because this is all over the internet by influencers,
penalty and CBD products. They go through this list of all these things that it cures,
which is a really big fallacy, especially when you're talking about CBD because it doesn't cure
anything. Well, it sounds like I'm being negative on CBD or not. I think CBD can be wonderful
for many things, but it's not a cure for anything. And CBD would not, if I was going to say,
what are some natural things I could do for a paid? CBD probably wouldn't be on that list.
So natural things you could do for pain, severe pain, let's say pain from an injury or pain from
cancer, really pretty much nothing natural is going to help that. Now, if you get muscle
sort of pain using Arnica, Usida, anti-inflammatories, which would be the flavonoids like
resveratrol, curcumin, as well, things like that can be very helpful and can help calm the area
and calm the pain. But if you got pain from cancer, pain from the tastasis, there is really no natural
thing that's going to take care of that. The only thing that would be close to that would be
a marijuana product, but not CBD. Remember, there's multiple different forms of CBD
and there's none of them would be anything that would recommend for pain. You'd have to get into
the psychotropic form of what comes from marijuana, the THC in order to really see anything valuable
in paid management. We've had people over the years take THC for paid, even smoking a marijuana
cigarette for paid and that was very helpful for some people. Now, it partly depends
upon the person. Some people are sensitive to cannabinoids. Some people are more or less sensitive
to them. Personally, I've never smoked marijuana. Personally, I've only tried the THC in the concentrated
Riximsym formula dose and I probably created a couple of videos back in the day when I did that.
When my cancer was really bad, I would never do it again unless I absolutely had to because it made
me so loopy. I just do not like feeling that way. So, I'll never use any kind of medications like that
or drugs like that and I just don't like not being fully aware of my senses. Now, I would say it
probably would take care of pain if you were taking THC in a dose that made you pretty loopy.
The negative is that it makes you pretty loopy. So, it's not necessarily a great choice either
for that reason. And you could argue that, well, I don't want to take morphine. I don't want to take
these oxycodones. I don't want to take these addictive substances. Those aren't good for me either.
Well, I understand that. That's where you have to kind of make a decision. Now, you could still
take a medication for pain. We have a number of people that are at a federal patch and they can still
function. They can still drive. They could still work if they had to. If you were taking THC
in the high dose that makes you the, you couldn't function. You couldn't go to work. You couldn't
drive. You couldn't do anything. So, you have to weigh out those factors when you're trying to
deal with pain. Now, I don't think anybody should just try to suffer it out. Pain just rags
you down. It rags the energy out of you. It's just not good for you. Now, always, whenever you have
a symptom, pain as a symptom, you do have to investigate why you have the pain. But if your pain,
the reason why you have the pain was already determined, let's add, the substances to my,
to my spine. And I'm having this horrible pain in my spine that this will not go away.
And, you know, you're, you've already investigated, you know, maybe doing radiation on that spot and
you've investigated other treatments that are more invasive than, you know, alternative things you're
doing. But you're still waiting on that or whatever and you just need to deal with the pain.
It's pretty hard to not just go to a drug source to deal with that and it's
and to say, you know, as an alternative doctor that you don't need to do that, you should just take
this or you get, that's just not true. There's some things that we have to turn to medications for.
You know, there isn't any natural thing that's going to get rid of that type of pain. So,
we don't want to be so alternatively minded that we were dogmatic about it and then we hurt
ourselves. So, we have to be a little bit open minded to be willing to do some other things.
You could say that, you know, God gave men wisdom to make all sorts of things, even though I might,
might be bent at not trying those things first, but when we have to go to something, that's what it's
there for.